hello guys i'm greg i'm john i'm andrew
where today cuz we're gonna recap it in
movie news of the week of September of
the 12th of the addicted death so first
story today solely Clint Eastwood movie
starring Tom Hanks flu Sully
Sullenberger I saw this movie last night
I haven't released my movie review of it
I'm really glad this film's doing well
it's the second week in a row where
Clint Eastwood's new film has topped the
box office people were expecting that
maybe Blair Witch my beaded out blur
which is actually under bright warming
you know i'll subtract your little
surprised by that little surprise is
underperforming so much because it's
been so many years and like it's an
iconic movie like I feel like people
would have turned up and especially like
you know it's a pretty good trailer I
mean this is cool for Tom Hanks because
Tom Hanks doesn't had a film where he's
been number one at the box office in
almost a decade actually yeah no car
sure and I would say Clint Eastwood he's
had a pretty good track record his last
a few films of the one last year had
with Bradley Cooper that American sniper
I me show my money so I'm in dead
kleeneze which is on a good a good tear
right now so this doesn't shock me in
terms of his movie being on top but I
thought Blair Witch when i made like you
said a little more money for sure and
bridget jones i don't recall these
movies ever making much money well you
seem a little surprised that like oh
it's not doing well at the box off so
I'm lycra nails Renee Zellweger she
hasn't been hot at the box office in a
very very long time and the Bridget
Jones movies are like they're so spread
apart the sequels and there are some
limited fan base for them too they're
also coming back from a pretty pretty
poorly received second movie too so like
you know I've heard pretty good things
about about the third Bridget Jones it's
not as broad of an appeal yeah and also
like you said it's been a long time
since the last movie didn't even
I mean not even stuck in my mind that
when the last film even came out so I
have no interest in really seeing it
even though I have heard some okay
things as well that's more of a rent to
kind of movie for me all right so Hugh
Jackman's last outing as Wolverine from
Wolverine three bryan singer has
confirmed that mr. sinister will be the
villain in wolverine 3 I saw the show
growing up and I know he's like a big
part of season 2 of the show the
animated series did you see the anime
series I love the animated yeah yeah
like you said he was a big part of that
but I just loved like this character in
general just his back story of how I
spoilers if an you don't know this
backstory he lost his wife and his child
and apocalypse gave him his powers and
you just such a really cool girl he's
got super speed he's immortal you can do
a lot of damage so it shen all right
crazy yeah it's just going to be
interesting to see him in a solo
wolverine foam it's gonna be interesting
to see then you mentioned Bryan Singer's
winter nelson by believe Bryan Singer's
the producer and james mangold the
director the second wolverine film is
directing this oh yeah I'm really
interested to see the infusion of
sinister into this it's going to be
interesting because I'm a big fan of
this character and they really are
trying to make a much bigger Cinematic
Universe here you know like introducing
apocalypse grana what you think about
the film in terms of just a villain that
was like the biggest bill and the x-men
franchise has had thus far they're
really making it time because Xmen
apocalypse only had a Wolverine cameo
but it ends with what'swhat's signatures
reeling Nathaniel Essex and you see
Essex core oh yeah in case which is
linking to Wolverine dairy so there
really are making their Cinematic
Universe more defined what I'm
interested in seeing is how Wolverine
will take him down I know a big part of
Sinister's backstory is he he's weak to
Cyclops's beams yes cycle office and
does it seem like it'd be a part of this
movie but it wouldn't be surprising if
he was if he if he likes began at the
end of the fit yeah just you know the
ending dude it seems like an impossible
villain for Wolverine to take down and
also some mr. sinister he deals a lot
with cloning so I imagine that at the
end of Apocalypse well they're probably
hinting at is easy to try to somehow
clone is weapon x DNA which might lead
to x 23 which is the Wolverine in the
comics i believe currently right yeah
the female will grin
female wolverine that'd be really cool
yeah need you have you really me
personally I mean just I want to see
Bryan Cranston play mr. sinister I think
that'd be a really good choice I be a
great choice when I hope today I know
he's supposed to have you know like a
certain amount of intellect and I hope
they play that up yeah I hope they use
that to their advantage and don't just
go with all the cool powers in [ __ ]
we're gonna fight yeah not die and end
the world one big world ending event i
want it i want also to like the stem you
know I want the stakes to be high for
sure but I don't want it to be another
world ending event you know keep the
keep it more to personal the story you
know and gal gadot as X 23 is how they
should talk about the French is
interesting Mad Max fury road news I
mean it was one of the biggest oscar
surprises of the last saucer event
because it one like the most officers
did in it there's a lot what so many
obstacles Amongus big ones like director
and those been doing a lot of tech yeah
we're not gonna give you the prestige
award like the only i know lord we're
gonna give you everything I've I could
love you do and I mean there's two
exciting things about it first one is
it's been officially announced at the
black and white edition because George
Miller did set out to originally make
fury road and black and white which I'm
glad he did it I think it's much cooler
that they're giving us the black and
white edition in December as a special
release because after seeing the movie
in color it's like yeah I would have
been a little bummed out that if black
and white was the only addition we got
first well actually like the choice when
they when they couldn't go with wagon
when I thought that kind of helped make
the movie even more interesting because
they went the opposite of the color
palette we usually get for these movies
so everything is so orange or so blue is
beautiful yeah yeah it was like very
striking and to have all that color is
kind of amazing but I love black and
white so I'm excited for this the idea
of seeing in color and then seeing it in
black white that does sound like
something that's special you know what I
mean and also to for people who aren't
into the idea of black and white great
here you go you get your version in
December people who like in color you
already got your version so you get the
best of both worlds so I like the idea
the other story with a fury road that
I'm a little not too interesting like
this one is a big rumor
they might do a prequel the fury road
based more on furiosa some rumors are
saying that it might be a ballon ferio
so was working with immortan joe and
they were saying that George Miller
would helm this one too it just doesn't
seem like it's along the lines of what
George Miller would do because here he
said that he has like two stories
already really thought out that he wants
to follow up with fury road this doesn't
seem along the lines at all to me just
sounds like a rumor I don't know if
Aereo says a cool supporting character I
don't know if I'm even though she was
like pretty much became the lead of fury
road I don't know I wouldn't want to
really see a Mad Max movie without Mad
Max and I like a madman I like for the
next Mad Max to get more of Mad Max in
there too I don't dislike the idea of
seeing more furiosa Center movie I'd
rather see a sequel though yes like the
prequel I almost feel like you know like
almost like durian necessary yeah it's
like we got fury road and we got like a
critical point in this woman's life and
now I want to see where she goes it's
like we already get what happened before
I don't need to see it in greater
details as much for my own like longing
you know as a moviegoer Justice League I
honor Batman day that just happened
recently they released a still a black
and white still of Commissioner Gordon
JK Simmons standing by the bat light and
looking at bats that light path signal
waiting for daddy to show up but you
were saying that you have some theories
about this yeah I think I was ringing a
little bit about some of the set reports
i believe all for the Justice League
member or not all them but for them
Wonder Woman Batman flash and cyborgs at
some point comes on here I believe
cyborgs father has been kidnapped by
parademons and now cyborg is now that's
why he's willing to join the Justice
League now to help you know rescue his
father Wow yeah getting back to this
this picture of JK Simmons he just looks
like Commissioner Gordon to me yeah no I
like the look of in and like i said this
scene from everything i've been reading
it sounds like at the end of it when
they'll find out what their mission or
what they have to do they all like storm
off really fast and the flash is the
only one left there with Commissioner
Gordon and like looking at him like whoa
they think they go fast like that I goes
yeah
do that but it's like oh yeah I write a
report yeah it's funny like flashes used
the first one is so for him to be
shocked and like on a team where guys
are like any other fast i just i like
that cohesion that chemistry gist of
what I'm hearing about the seven parts
and and like I said just seeing JK
Simmons he just looks like Commissioner
Gordon strata the conversation maybe
yeah and I know Justice Lee they want it
and they're intentionally trying to
infuse more humor into the DCE you now
especially with geoff johns on board now
they're trying to make it much more
light and to stick to the to the themes
that really bring these characters to
life and bring some hope and some
humanity back to it and I feel like JK
Simmons is a great addition for it
because I mean JK Simmons we all know
he's an amazing dramatic actor but he
also excels in comedic was jonah Jameson
yeah that wanted to this day I think
that is probably the best adapted comic
with character right out of the top of
that right on Hades no prettier that's I
wouldn't argue that a minute Tony Stark
Robert I drew those are to the top ones
i feel like if they're gonna try to
infuse more humor i feel like to get a
great dramatic hackers also excels in
comedy I think JK Simmons is a perfect
choice for Commissioner Gordon yeah you
can gonna split the difference and and
I'm really excited to see what he does
with this character especially having
seen him play Jay jonah Jameson so many
times like to do something a little bit
different but in the same you know
corner of the video store I'm excited
daddy can I do I couldn't agree more
with you guys the Golan questions I want
to see if he throws a chair at Ben
Affleck and tries to say interesting and
also an honor of Batman day they
actually I know released a photo Batman
looking a lot like night owl good night
out looked a lot like Batman so in one
minute isn't that how it's supposed to
be kind of a riff on bad yeah he is and
also Zack Snyder directed Watchmen so
it's it's all coming full circle and
Batman V Superman has some Easter eggs
towards Watchmen which kind of makes
sense because I know watchman's down the
DC Universe his photo looks really cool
of that man this doesn't strike me as
his main suit though no like I have a
group and batman be superman like the
main dark knight dark knight returns to
do yeah then again it's not it's on Ying
it the whole time and this feels like
this will probably be the special suit
that he goes to at some point because
even Zack Snyder says a tactical that's
you yeah no I agree i would say he
probably like you said he needs this
to be agile and for defense I'd say
against parademons would be my guess you
know Darkseid and Steppenwolf's minions
so he's gonna and again the action
scenes we saw in Batman V Superman where
him in Superman or fighting where he's
in that armor suit it's cool but it was
a little bit clunky to when he's moving
around in the suit so from an agile
perspective and how much quicker and
faster he's going to look I love the
look at this I don't mind the goggles
yet is a little night album whatever so
what it's Batman can wear anything he
wants he's gonna look sick as hell and
again I do like the tactical look like
you said of the armor plates and
everything it does look like a variation
of the Arkham Knight and kind of like a
Christopher Nolan suit infused with some
armor so it does literally sick Jay
chambers and if in terms of the goggles
too i mean like i did you tell watchmen
twice i don't remember the goggles
playing a significant part in a suit
other than the aesthetic look yeah um I
feel like you that man though the
goggles will probably be a very specific
thing that yeah does something specific
to allow him to enhance his abilities
and whatever situation is in yeah second
law I'm all right with this is like the
way we do comic book movies now
especially it seems like of course he's
got like multiple suits for different
you know a kid like different yeah does
in different terrains in different
situations that's official Tom Cruise is
finally officially signed on to be in
Mission Impossible 6 there's been a lot
of talks about like contract disputes
and I know it's gonna start filming in
mid 27 or supposed to originally start
filming in january twenty seventeen
minus they see 27 yeah the gym the
mission of possible franchise is the one
thing that has really kept Tom Cruise's
career strongly afloat because when he
was coming out like I'm in love with
katie holmes and all the scientology
angeles lakers coach his movies were not
doing well and even mission impossible 3
wasn't doing well and i remember when
people felt that his comeback was like
his strong steady comeback was really
happening was with ghost Protocol yeah
and then the rogue nation to me was one
of my favorite films of 2015 i'm excited
he's returning for it I never doubted
for a second that you wouldn't return
for it yeah it's more like what the [ __ ]
oh look guys it's all those contracts
cuz they're gonna cross it over the Fast
and Furious yeah yeah no I mean my whole
thing was that like you I knew he was
going to sign at some points like you
see how much money the last two films in
May and also the last few Tom Cruise
phones from edge of tomorrow and and
mission impossible 5 mission impossible
for Jack Reacher I mean these are some
really good movies and Tom Cruise is
worth the money so I I knew it was going
to happen eventually I would have been
pissed if it wouldn't have happened so
I'm glad it finally got worked out
something makes me feel like they were
kind of holding some stuff against him
because I feel like Tom Cruise's movies
the only films that Tom Cruise seems to
do in the states that do exceptionally
well in the States domestically are the
Mission Impossible films I feel like his
other films and even like edge of
tomorrow which is like an amazing film
it pretty much performed really well
overseas not so badly marketed in my
pants yeah it was and one people weren't
clear on what the title was yeah I
thought it was I thought it was more
like that other video game movie he just
done with morgan freeman what was the
the one called the one we version one
frame Tom Cruise Morgan Freeman they
just done it like a year or two before
that was like a from a video game movie
this [ __ ] up there what yeah I should
know this off the top of my head until
instructor guys doing like every Tom
Cruise movie Tom Curren Oh oblivion
oblivion oh yeah Olivia actually liked
it but that was another one where it did
well to mess it didn't do that well
domestically but it did really well
overseas because i feel like it before
less sensitive to his public persona
overseas well i'm not excited for it is
the mummy reboot things I am I really
yeah it hurts I read the whole plot
description of it I I read the blog i've
seen set photos and I'm just like this
is not seem like it's gonna really be
that you're not I feel you but like I
said the last like four or five Tom
Cruise phones have come out recently I
really enjoyed grandma they were more
action you know mystery-solving films
and most of them and this is more in the
horror genre which is not really tom
cruise's forte less well i hope it's the
horror genre is the thing cuz i've heard
their plan to make like a cinematic
universe I get more kind of action
adventure ii I really do hope that
they're gonna keep the horror at least
strongly represented there I'd love to
see Tom honestly I would like to see Tom
crews in a horror movie yeah interview
with the vampire I mean I don't know if
you would kill that bore but that's why
my lassie like his real taste of war but
it's like a homo erotic thriller we have
were elevated again just adding to what
you said no I don't mind if they go the
action-adventure route in the new mummy
but i do want a lot of horror elements
infused in there you know not st. jump
scares but just that feeling of you know
suspension where he'd be exactly like
I'm not looking forward to that but I am
certainly open edit it could be good and
I hope it's good like I want it to work
I'd like to see the universal monsters
come back and I'd like to see like it
sounds like they want all their plan
reminded me of Van Helsing and that's a
movie I really wanted to be good because
he could been like so I hope that they
made that chance work now but but the
meantime we could see tom cruise and
Jack Reacher never go back with Kobe
spawned oh so this message Tobias mudlow
cuz i was actually looking forward to
that but i really wish christopher
mcquarrie was coming back but i do like
edward zwick directing the new jack
reacher of his last outing with Tom
Cruise was the last samurai film I
really enjoyed so I'm curious to see
what edward zwick does with Tom Cruise
again star wars the force awakens has a
new competitor that's not Star Trek it's
fifty shades darker yeah fifty shades
darker is taught the force awakens as
the most viewed trailer in the first 24
hours which obviously is kind of
shocking to me i'm actually not some for
some reason i'm not super duper
surprised it's just amusing i find it
very surprising because star wars is an
exceptionally more built-in fan base and
it's been around for way longer Fifty
Shades of Grey is only prior source
material is a shitty first movie with
okay books I guess what it's such a
ubiquitous phenomenon that you got to
imagine you have the people who it's or
checking in and then you have the other
people with the morbid curiosity going I
gotta see this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
this yeah not only then I think too it
also proves that there's a lot of horny
people out there wanting to see if how
much nudity they're gonna see in a
trailer 2 and way too big the main set
pieces you know they're gonna be in the
film that's gonna draw them into to see
the film just kinda sad because the
fifty shades darker trailer is just kind
of
Trey I didn't see like there's nothing
about around like why is this such a
popular idea yeah I think that's why so
many people tune into is you know cuz
the first movie is kind of underwhelming
in terms of how steamy it is and so I
think people wanted to see like are they
really gonna double down and the answer
appears to be not really I didn't see it
but I heard that the beginning says like
forget the past or something it's like
or I tried to erase the Opera yet over
yeah he's like all right I have so
agents of shield which is weird because
it's kind of like the first Marvel show
out of the MCU and it seems to be the
little one around that no one really
gives a [ __ ] about I feel like like a
seal gets a lot of passes they're like
hey everybody loves Marvel we gotta keep
this [ __ ] I would do a cross overs we
cannot stop I think it's great what
they're doing I think it's clever
marketing and it's the first time where
I'm like I want to see agents of shield
no because yeah I mean they got ghost
rider in there now and everyone knows
that Ghost Rider was like not a great
two films with Nic Cage ghost rider is
like a guilty pleasure best yes rod yeah
exactly and goes on farm good what I
gotta say though is I think it's cool i
got gabriel Luna plan like asses like
the first like Latino actors are getting
a play a superhero and I think it's cool
they got a Hispanic actor to play such a
well known Marvel hero who was
previously played by white guy you know
and I don't know the source material if
ghost writer that well I don't know if
like he's hispanic or wipe to top it off
like this adds a new edge to agents of
shield because ghost riders a very dark
character he kills people and it seems
like they're kind of trying to bring a
Punisher vibe of what they did with
daredevil season two absolutely it seems
like to try and do the same thing here
but instead of just a guy who goes on
like mass killings that this guy you
know you know talks with spirits and
demons and [ __ ] you know yeah graded I'm
only up to season 2 episode 1 of this
show but I mean I think they were just
get them and go to this one yeah yeah
watch but I mean now I'm gonna watch a
lot quicker but granted like in the
first season there's a lot of
name-dropping about Thor about Iron Man
by Captain America
and it just like this is like you said
from a marketing standpoint this makes
me want to watch it a lot quicker and
get into a lot more and I think you made
a great comparison on what they did with
Punisher and daredevil was such a just
his tragic backs right now they infused
it and do it I'm really intrigued like
just from what the lil footage and
snippets we've seen it looks really
intriguing I don't know a lot about a
ghost rider or either in terms of the
source material but I think he might
have been there's a few different
variations and I think one of them might
actually been Hispanic in the comments
that drive the cars I see I think I
think they are actually sticking the
compaq roots here I could be wrong but I
believe they are but it's cool they're
just getting a Latino character and then
yeah yeah sure what and I mean that that
promo they put out for him looks badass
like that looks more along the lines of
the stuff they're doing on netflix than
a no oh yeah exactly because the netflix
marble shows are dark and it's cool that
they're at their adding that dark edge
into agents of shield now because they
just shield I just couldn't get into I
mean I try watching the whole first
season I just really couldn't get into
it and I know a lot of people have the
heart I have a hard time game to that
show beyond the other Netflix shows and
I feel like this is kind of taking
inspiration from that I know the Russo
brothers were actually acknowledging in
a recent interview that they might start
thinking about for infinity they're
talking about about actually including
the characters in the television show is
they really need a show to do what look
I mean I wanna get into a whole infinity
war talk but just from that perspective
like if they are going to include
characters in the show I don't mind that
it's just there's going to be a lot
going on those phones with famous and
obviously everything I don't mind if
like the world's ending or something
Crazy's upcoming and we see just a shot
of like the the defenders in New York
and we see ghost rider and I'm looking
up in the sky like they're fighting the
same kind of battle it's just they're
not the main focus of the film just
acknowledging oh there there a part of
this it's just we're not going to focus
a crazy amount of them because there's
going to be an inordinate important
amount of characters in The Avengers
infinity War I mean I mean they said 67
I don't know if I believe that number
but there's gonna be like a while back
that's what they were saying that was
the number but I mean who knows how many
characters was gonna be like i said this
just the this really intrigues me and I
just I want to catch up now much quicker
now on agencies yeah well this might be
able to solve the Kannada because
ancient
in an odd position because they are a
network show and network shows have
certain earmarks and certain aesthetic
feelings you know and things they can't
really go for and at least like I said
that promo looks like they're doubling
down on the grit and me and the effects
to look for TV yeah we good totally now
this was an interesting report that came
out this week to Rebecca Hall who played
Maya Hansen in iron man 3 she revealed
that she was supposed to be the original
main villain in iron man 3 which of
course if you guys saw it they made it
aldric aldrich killian peasant yes a
legit alien which is weird because I
think I have all Marvel films that's the
most debated one because of its twists
of the Mandarin and all that [ __ ] that
happens and then this is just another
article that just like adds to that
films like debating controversy yeah
because I I did feel this character was
not the most necessary like halfway
through the film I felt like she wasn't
that necessary hearing the way they
wrote it is kind of like i see like i
felt that way to see what happened here
in the big studio came in well ya later
right yeah definitely you said like the
first half of that movie she was being
built up more to be like that villain
type of character and then just out of
nowhere just got shot so i mean it
doesn't make sense what she's saying i
just what i find funny is they just they
didn't find an appeal der because they
wanted to sell toys i guess but it's
like oh it's good black girl toys who's
it about Aldrich Killian yeah like who's
waving around they're all your chili do
it's like who's got an altered killing
toys around right now favorite villain
hands down killing I'm the Mandarin they
are making kind of a men's now they got
Captain Marvel Khmer on Black Widow is a
much bigger fan character though at some
point maybe I wouldn't maybe possibly
like to see a solo filmers of Joss
Whedon's directing it I'd actually be
very interested in that they are doing a
little more you know with the MCU TV
shows we got Jessica Jones ya know so
they are doing a lot of you know bigger
and better things for female character
so I do like that they are righting
wrongs but it's kind of upsetting a
little bit and also laughable that they
thought thought selling toys would would
be there you know why they wanted to
kill this character and also I find it
hysterical when Rebecca Hall says they
just came up to me in the middle of
and said how would you what would you
feel if you got shots like um yeah
that's different than what I read in is
here that would you do gosh I ya know
where I could just imagine being in her
position a ragam patience at like how
hurtful that was born yeah actress to
feel like you feel like it finally got
this year's about it nobody had your
back yeah way through you're not the
villain in here cuz we gotta sell
village children yeah I remember
watching iron man 3 and liking that part
of how like pepper potts was a little
bit intimidated and threatened by her
the love trying yeah yeah then I thought
that her in a Robert Downey hi good
chemistry and even her and Gwyneth
Paltrow active chemistry so she was a
good character I mean they could
released kept her around so just killing
her awesome we cannot have you in
instead they kill her off with if you
watch the film it's a big continuity air
aldrich killian has no gun in his hand
he's got his bare hands and next shot
he's just got a gun in his hand kills
her was just badly for how people he is
you can just conjure gonna that what use
the mini is the mandarin hundred and
eighty year old legend Stan Lee is gonna
be getting a biopic finally I mean no
that's crazy this guy's like what 93
right now 94 late December is he gonna
make a cameo in it they'll probably be
the star oh they're gonna do a biopic
about him the interesting thing about it
I i I'm actually drawn to the idea of it
is their pitching it as an
action-adventure movie yeah which is
cool it kind of reminds me of
confessions of a dangerous mind that
George Clooney directed at charlie
kaufman script Sam Rockwell started it
and that was a biopic but they kind of
made it like a spy movie at the same
time of this like game show host in like
especially when they dived into his mind
and stuff okay and I feel like that's
kind of like what they'll probably do
here I mean I don't imagine they're
gonna like really alter facts of things
I imagine they'll probably cut from
reality then to Stanley's imagination at
the time and then we go into that you
know make it like a comic book I could
be totally off here kind of sounded a
little bit not a from little snippets
just like a little bit of goosebumps
we're like you know how jack black is
playing RL stine and like his books now
are coming to life i was thinking yeah
yeah that would be cool
that means a some steve king I mean the
quote that we got here is that's gonna
be a 1970s a picture has been described
as being in the tone of Kingsman Secret
Service and Roger Moore's
double-oh-seven specifically Roger Moore
some of those everybody has a lot to
[ __ ] and shaking my question is who's
gonna play Stanley I mean obviously I
know you're gonna say Stanley but lake
and real I was really gonna play
standard outlet they were mall rat they
were mall rat children are wired into
our family Clint Eastwood Tom Hardy do
you think they're gonna do what they did
in captain america civil war and ant-man
where they get their the younger digital
version like a Robert Downey jr. Michael
Douglas where they make their face look
younger yeah issue that was anything but
make him still sound 93 years old look
at my voices sounded like this since I
was four I won't Jay jonah Jameson
spider-man I thought of human spider
what every tells his stories and I came
up with his character of a simple things
he thought of lovelessness I thought
what if a man got angry angry like the
year Stanley is like slowly turning into
half Elvis yeah it's not examine my
impression that deep okay so many years
ago I saw a movie in the theaters that
was a delightful surprise really wasn't
expecting to just wildly enjoy to this
day if i watch it again I think it's
great the rundown uh Peter Berg that
really put him on the map in terms of
like really as a director because I know
he did acting before I feel like a lot
of you'll don't remember that klavier
very first thing I vs yes ray wasn't
collateral Colin excusing comment used
the partner of Mark Ruffalo in calando
barely any memory may not Copland yeah
yeah where he's like kind of abusive to
his wife no no anyway yeah Peter Burke
he did the rundown and that was a first
movie I saw with with the rock where I
was like whoa did a good job actually
yeah before that he had you know the
score being king yeah
Brussels did yeah and he's barely in the
mummy returns so was enough to really
judge his acting really do that up and
then he showed them visually I'm like
what the head when I saw in theaters
like that's a joke but the run I thought
he was great I like the whole cast is
great I don't it doesn't sound like
they're interesting against Shawn
Williams house her rich friends which
sucks because I thought I thought Shawn
winged skull was hilarious on his own
but I thought him and Dwayne Johnson
worked so [ __ ] well together once
it's like that would be a nice chance to
bring him back I mean I don't know what
he's doing now but I know a lot of
people really like that movie did a
couple years ago called goon it's a
hockey yeah that was good and Leia I
know people who are clamoring for him to
come back after that so like it kind of
bums me out there yet Adam I've seen the
run down to several times and for me to
i feel like that movie that's right
before arnold schwarzenegger became
governor of california i feel like that
film he's a baby camion it I feel like
that move is kind of a passing of the
torch Arnold took the rock like have fun
like you're taking over from you as the
action star I'm going into politics so I
kind of felt like it's that you nailed
in the head I love the chemistry in the
cohesion between sean william scott and
doing the wrong johnson and and i'm all
for Jonah Hill being in the sequel if
they do actually make it I just would
like sean william scott to be in there
somewhere as well because that was a big
part of I mean obviously I did love the
action film I I love st. Christopher
Walken as the villain and the previous
in the film is well the first film but
the main draw for me in that film was
the chemistry between the rock and shale
boom yeah and I just really enjoyed all
the scenes the between them and I
thought they had great chemistry so at
the minimum i want to see sean william
scott night i wouldn't even say cameo
but i want to see him back in somewhat
of a little bit of a prolific role but
if worst case scenario i guess here we
go cameo but i think they should do is
get Kevin Hart instead of shamili now
that seems to be the go-to move Jumanji
males intelligence yeah I feel like this
would be Kevin horses lunch at a man
[ __ ] Jack Johnson and Jack Black what
no really give about Jeb black coat and
rage can I Rio and it's not a very it's
it's a continuous it's not as I would
guess I don't know sequel but it's a
continuation story they won't mention
Alan Parrish Robin Williams character in
the film I mean in this interview though
with Peter Berg he mentions Jonah Hill 1
2 3 4 5 thank you really my decided
a little bit like three days time to
like the research on William who he
clearly wants to do the run down to with
I mean Dwayne Johnson's on borz he's
like Dwayne Johnson's one I do any
everybody yeah that guy just doesn't
sleep he's worse out and read scripts
and films in the wrestling man yeah he's
not a that he runs when you go to WWE
he's got an HBO show and he's got it
he's got a family and he's gonna fail it
geez but his family's falling apart is
it maybe oh I'm going to assume so cuz
he's never there yeah how is he that's a
matter of time dostum when I were my kid
um but with Jonah Hill though that we
let me cool is he Jonah Hill in the rock
going back and forth mm-hmm I don't
really know what I'd rather there's no
disc details of what Peter Berg want to
do with the run down to other than I
really want Dwayne Johnson and Jonah
Hill to be in it you know yeah I mean I
I'd like to see them team up I kind of
rather see them team up in something
that's not the run down again just just
because like when you come back to a
property that had an important chemistry
at the core of it I feel like it's never
the same when you replace that chemistry
yeah I agree and I'm not comparing this
to the nice guys the new film that just
came out which is a film I really
enjoyed but the chemistry between Ryan
Gosling and Russell Crowe that's like
saying they're gonna make the nice guys
too with no Ryan Gosling a nuclear add
they're just gonna yeah who cares like
oh yeah that's interesting we're like
doing a lethal weapon show for foie oh
don't even get me started without stop
stop Danny girly angry right now all
right last story of the day it was
reported that uh uh I said I said
Michael interdisciplinary swab will no
longer be scoring rogue one Michael
Giacchino that's who's an Italian like
Italians Michael Giacchino will actually
be scoring road one which is really
exciting he's done a lot of awesome
films I mean I have a filmography look
this is rob uh yeah he's my one my
favorite maybe he's done a lot of JJ
abrams star 3 star trek starting and
darkness I think he's mission impossible
ghost protocol and this is nah he might
have I would be surprised if he did
which is a lot of trouble water eggsy
incredibles yeah and now that's bad
ghost Protocol so I'm sure it's Michael
no
yes in terms of the direction that Star
Wars has been going granted i want Road
want to be its own standalone piece and
not feel like it has to succumb to
certain franchise things I mean I'm sure
that the original composer they have
would have been great but based off the
works of Michael Giacchino and who and
the fact that he's worked with JJ Abrams
a lot that this he probably seems like
he'd be a stronger choice in terms of
the music for this and just looking off
the footage of that we've got her number
01 I feel like the music that I've heard
of him do that he would have that and i
like i love like the star trek and the
star trek into darkness music yeah I
feel like he'll do it he'll do a good
job still I mean I was excited because
because I I really enjoyed us fly every
time I like I usually find myself
enjoying the music and then I'll see his
name in the credits ago oh like yeah I'm
bummed to see him go but [ __ ] chinos
done some great work too it's a two-way
street for me I'm a very big disk block
fan if you have not heard the soundtrack
for Harry Potter the Deathly house part
two I really advise you to listen it's
amazing it's epic I was really looking
forward to seeing what he was going to
do with this on the flip side I do like
giacchino a lot like you said up inside
out the first two Star Trek films he's
done a lot of films that I love the
scores too so I am why I'm looking for
then I am rather curious as to what the
heck happened with this plot like
because they said according to what we
were reading it said that there was some
scheduling complex due to extensive
reshoots and maybe that's true like look
I'm not as half as busy as displaying I
think maybe a quarter is busy but the
point I'm making is I get it hectic
schedules happening but this is a Star
Wars ma'am scheduling conflicts for a
Star Wars movie it's just I don't know
i'm not saying their line but i have a
hard time believing this story that
that's the exact reason he left so maybe
it was just like I get work man they're
gonna make a million of these Star Wars
movies i'll hit you on the next time
maybe but again the to follow John
Williams and Star Wars I just I feel
like there's more a little more to this
story than I had some schedule complex
due to extensive reshoots cuz reshoots
happen all the time in films like you
know composers make do with what they
have in its star wars I'm sure whatever
is filmography is now he would have said
guys I'm doing Star Wars can we like
push back a little something but that's
the contention with this movie's is we
don't know what kind of reshoots
the rumors are that they you know Disney
wanted to change a lot of the tone and
change a lot of the things I heard how
dis plot was sleeping with gareth
edwards and then in the middle of
shooting they broke up is it nasty
breakup yeah yeah they can't work
another is just you know a man yes it's
got stay professional yes a pro and of
course they were fighting a lot this is
why you don't mix business and pleasure
of people there's a reason why a bedroom
is in a home you know Helena Bonham
Carter and tim burton what happened to
them they're done they're done but she's
still starring in ellis in Wonderland
films I mean I mean right directed I say
you produced it yeah you doesn't gotta
be on settling like you know those were
a couple phone calls he's like hey guys
it's really gross two billion dollar
actually you've gotta blink because they
knew the new x-men or I mean Tim
Burton's x-men miss Pellegrin whatever
that movies cuz evergreen yeah there you
go looks like an x-men movie timber
other Elena but I was gonna say they
picked eva green and even reanimated Tim
Burton one yeah rose mcgowan was to a
rubber rod v yeah but good to you cheat
um yeah I mean based off the filmography
Michael Giacchino just I it just sounds
like he's better suited for it makes a
lot of sense yeah especially with all
the star treks and stuff because the new
structure movies are a lot like story
yeah I my hair to say is better i'm not
the biggest expert my dashing orchestra
right and i live exactly i'm with you i
love them both i well I'm sure that the
score that giacchino is going to come
out with is gonna be epic and phenomenal
i'm still gonna and I'm gonna enjoy
every second I'm still gonna have that
little backwards thing a feeling in my
head like I wonder what this plot says
score would have sounded like but I'm
still again i'm still looking very
forward to giacchino he's a very good
composer so you know I'm not too
bothered by this I'm just curious my
whole thing is I'm just curious why this
plot left other than maybe he slept with
gareth edwards obviously yes well backed
the way things work now I'm actually
kind of curious about this like I hope
that you know like 10 years from now he
releases some of that music that he was
right on the board it'll pop up
somewhere else you know
i'd be down for that all right guys
let's the movie news of the week I'm not
sure if we'll have movie news next week
I'm going to Switzerland on Wednesday
that's a that no ah got already a guy
got invited to the Zurich Film Festival
so it's a really big honor they're gonna
fly out there and I'm gonna get the
press badges and everything hopefully
Mel Gibson's therefore hacksaw ridge
that's what I'm so I heard them if you
got a 10-minute oh baby after the pelvis
like where people were standing for
tennis clapping dude Greg's gonna go for
20 I'm gonna go for a late are you
talking talking to his QA down please
yeah thank you but stop sooner be in
Zurich in a couple days I'm gonna be
there for about a week so I don't know
if uploads will be whatever but yeah
hopefully you stayed through this whole
movie new segment you're new to the
channel subscribe to the rail line
chicks on Instagram and Twitter john is
a treasonous Jerry on Twitter he is at a
Gore 7-eleven he is the channel movie
source where he does reviews with his
cousin oh my god with Jason that's right
here just her today shakes go so many
times and John he has the playlist year
reasons to Jerry as well and he's the
social media manager facebook.com / boom
house facebook.com slash the real
rejects and even though this is some of
the most thought and opinions we put
into a video we know it's not going to
get more views than us doing a reaction
thank you for being here